إذا نظرت إلى المملكة اليوم عندما
بدأت في وزارة الرياضة ، لم يكن لدينا
أي امرأة في الرياضة ، فلدينا أكثر من 300 امرأة في
طور الإعداد ، لكن هؤلاء 300
رياضي لا يبلغ عددهم حوالي 150000 في
عالم الرياضة الموسع عندما ننظر إلى
الثقافة  عندما ننظر إلى وزارة
الخارجية ، لدينا الآن خمس
دبلوماسيات في جميع أنحاء العالم ، وتمثلنا
إحداهن اليوم في
مناصب الاتحاد الأوروبي التي يمكن للمرأة الآن
أن تطمح إليها ولكنك تتحدث
أيضًا عن التغيير الاجتماعي للعقل وهذا
ما هو حاسم في التغيير الاجتماعي
للعقل هو النظر إلى المرأة على قدم المساواة
وكفرصة لجميع
النساء اليوم لديهن نفس الألم في المملكة
اليوم تتمتع النساء بفرص متكافئة
قد لا تكون صحيحة في العديد من
البلدان الأخرى في العالم ، فكيف يمكن  نحن
بصفتنا المملكة العربية السعودية نقود في هذا الأمر ،
يمكننا أن نقود من خلال كوننا نموذجًا يحتذى به ليس
لمنطقتنا فحسب ، بل أود حقًا أن
أقول بصدق للعالم الإسلامي الممتد.